ah non c'était la toute première
émission
la toute première émission chacun son
tour et vous savez quoi le plus beau
cadeau que l'on puisse avoir ce sont les
audiences de l'émission puisque grâce à
vous qui nous regardait tous les matins
france 2 bat des records d'audience qui
n'avait pas été atteint le matin depuis
quelques années maintenant et c'est un
vrai plaisir de participer avec vous à
ce succès ça va du tissu en passant par
le cuir avec toute une gamme de couleurs
du noir du rouge les gens tentent d
éclat de rire evga tunis en train de me
dire à l'oreillette qu'on dirait le
plateau d amour setra jeu sans pareil
[Rires]
cherry a pas mal et non ma chérie du
tout un mec c'est pas votre chéri du
tout pardon excusez moi pardon c'est une
amie excusez-moi marion d'accord je vais
donc aymeric de ma part je salue aymeric
à votre chéri s'appelle et brille quand
le shérif de marion compris vous est
infirme bien donc dans les faits même
milieu médical aussi si
vous habitez ou pas oui en endoscopie
donc on fait tout ce qui est fibroscopie
colonoscopie gastroscopie on passe par
tous les trous quoi
[Rires]
titre tui travel direct type
je croyais en avoir vu beaucoup mais
vous plus que moi je pense que oui j'en
ai vu d'autres est
jeff ouais y'a aucune personnalité qui
se cache dans jean mariage et son
endroit donné
[Rires]
un compte twitter créé il ya maintenant
quelques mois cumul des dizaines de
millions de vues avec une idée simple
mettre des vélociraptors dans des
extraits de clips ou de films aussi
bizarre que cela puisse paraître le
succès est au rendez vous en témoigne
cette reprise de never gonna give you up
tubize il ya quatre jours et qui a
dépassé les 5 millions de vues
auld afida turner non
ça c'est exactement le projet à c'est le
sac
on ne sent pas les fesses
comme ça et là faut partir quand il est
content là que souvent fait ça voilà
sans aucun tir
voilé contents de me voir
on dirait qu'il est ensemble on dirait
ton fils
[Rires]
pas grave ça porte bonheur
ah oui
et la boule il va beaucoup merci
chanteur s'en prit
alors 300 euros à lecce la jolie marie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez chez vous
non c'est non parce que je lis et moi
non je rigole
[Rires]
discret mais ça va casser les couilles
[Musique]
sont en train de faire la grande lessive
c'est bien de voir des garçons faire la
lessive pour se faire beau avant la
ville
c'est touchant
qui est derrière les maîtres guide je
reconnais pas tes potes
sapé comme jamais
[Rires]
non c'est sûr que ray comme il pas tes
potes à abbasside bbc marseille bébé au
10 sport
tu sais pas la capitale